Welcome to the Udacity
iOS Developer Nanodegree.
I'm James.
>> And I'm Garrett.
>> And
we are iOS course managers at Udacity.
We're excited to join you on your
path to becoming an iOS developer.
In this nanodegree program,
you'll acquire the knowledge and
skills necessary to be hired as
an entry level iOS developer.
You'll hone your developer skills
with our videos, quizzes and
reading materials.
You will also be creating a portfolio
of apps and submitting them for
feedback from our awesome
iOS project reviewers.
>> This nanodegree program assumes you
have experience with an object oriented
programming language.
Don't worry if you
haven't used Swift yet.
If you're comfortable with terms like
classes, objects, inheritance and
polymorphism, you should be fine.
If not, we recommend taking
our beginning iOS nanodegree.
>> All of your apps will be built using
the newest stable release of Xcode.
If you don't have it installed yet,
you'll need to download
it to your Mac now.
To download Xcode, select the Apple
icon on the top left of your screen and
choose App Store.
You can search for Xcode here.
And whenever there is an update, you can
update it here in the App Store as well.
Xcode will allow you to run
your apps on iPhone and
iPad simulators right on your computer.
If you sign up for
a free Apple developer account,
you can also deploy your
apps to your own device.
We've included a link
on how to register for
an Apple developer account
in the notes below.